uh when we did that break i did some
sort of a cliffhanger about
uh being a female ceo in gaming does it
matter or
and what's it like for you is it that is
it is it a positive you get
easy to recruit or is it negative like
gamer dudes are like uh
what does she know about gaming i feel
mixed about this answer so of course
i'll just give you both sides of it yeah
so uh okay let me give you the
optimistic side
i have four kids three boys and a little
girl
so for her sake i don't want to be too
negative about it yeah because
we must give hope right and i think one
of the things that's so frustrating
not just about tech but in particular
gaming is just there's a dearth of women
there's not enough women i mean we try
everything we can to to recruit women
and get them in the door
that just if you're a woman i don't
think you go i know
i'll go into gaming yeah right it's
you're already going through the tech
barriers and then to go into this
segment of gaming i think that's tough
so there's not enough so i
very much want to encourage women to
join because until more women join i'm
not sure that things change that much
um i think what's tough about being a
female in
tech still to this day and it's
extremely frustrating to have you know
been you know by a lot of founders sides
and then be on the completely other side
of the table running a company
is not much has changed in terms of
i think you still don't get the
presumption of competence as a woman you
still need to
in every meeting i we literally were
just doing some fundraising and
i got asked twice during the roadshow if
whose assistant i was
so just stuff like that where i know
it's a little bit bizarre wait a second
come into the room and they're like oh
okay and you're
you're so-and-so's assistant well
presumably my name's in your calendar or
the company's names in the calendar
so i just don't i think women still have
to prove that they're
intelligent maybe that's why they do the
voice for whatever he called it
something yes it's some way to convey
intelligence and gravitas so i do think
a lot of these
odd behaviors pop up because women still
don't get the benefit of the doubt
okay i think a man is presumed to be
competent there are some exceptions to
that i'm just talking about generalities
yes
and if people are just patterned in here
bro here's a check
start writing checks i'm like all right
i think you know what i'm doing i think
it's like totally human it's like the
whole
what money ball was written about that
right it's like you look like jose
canseco you must be a great ball player
right so i just think people sort of
pattern recognize and i get why it
happens
it's just a drag um and i think
in gaming it's tough too because you got
a lot of people mobile's relatively new
right i mean these app stores didn't
exist so you've got a lot of people who
came from console
and being a gamer generally meant you
were a dude
you hung out in a cave all by yourself
yeah right and you
were super hardcore about headsets and
yes
said misogynistic crazy stuff so there's
this like what do you know about
did you play league of legends yeah do
that okay there's a lot of testing
of like what's your game bonafide is
because i'm not sure i might listen to
you unless
yeah interesting yeah so there's a lot
of that but the good news is
there's a woman in charge now and there
are
uh everybody wants to change the ratio
so that's good
very much so and i see a lot of young
women who are into gaming now there
seems to be something
changing i think as gaming well i do
think
gaming is already displacing most
categories of entertainment
and i think gaming is going to really
displace social networks
entirely really and so i think you know
for fortnight
one of it is huge and one of the reasons
it's huge
is that's the social glue between so
many people so if you don't know what's
going on in the game
and you don't really know you know
what's the latest skin
right or what's the latest dance you're
kind of lame like you need to know
basics in order to engage actually just
socially in in normal world environments
yeah like in the 80s we needed to know
the band members
like you didn't what you studied you
needed to know the drummer's name the
bass player's name you know the
the deep tracks the deep cuts the rare
tracks and i think fortnite's super
approachable so i think it is
introducing a bunch of little girls to
games
yeah my daughter is nine years old and
she's in minecraft all day now yeah
building stuff my five-year-old loves
minecraft i don't know if that's good or
bad she's probably too young to play
games but she actually likes it
and i think it's good because i i don't
know enough about it i i'm getting more
educated but it seems like they're
building stuff
yeah yeah and so she's like here's my
cat palace and she like i won't let her
have a cat cause i'm allergic to them
and she just built a cat palace and then
you know doing the dances yeah the floss
i know i know what the floss is okay
literally but if you do the floss now
you're really a loser like then you're a
boomer
only boomers do the flaws yeah if i do
the floss you know it's the i still just
when i do the floss that's the last
floss that's ever gonna be done that's
like the nail in the coffin
but you've killed it i killed them um i
went to
like the talent show last year okay
and literally the entire talent show was
people doing the floss no
yes oh doing all the fortnite oh yeah so
there were like 30 acts
and i'd say at least a third of them had
the floss or some other thing in it
yeah so see that's going to become the
social network that'll be people's
currency
so already in our games like one of the
really critical components of our games
is that it is really heavy into social
yeah so people get married i mean but
this is true for a lot of mmos but
you're really building it around the
social experience and allowing people to
kind of create their own game play based
on whatever social dynamic
and i think all games are moving in that
direction which is kind of groovy
it is cool it's creative yeah people
form tributes to other players like
their kids get sick they say all about
it you know it becomes a form of therapy
for people
these are really really strong community
connections